good architecture does have this great
propensity to amplify social forces
technology and place and culture are
these very powerful operating forces
when I make public buildings I'm
compelled to kind of dissolve any sense
of hierarchies which are disconcerting
that maybe comes to my background Union
of multiple identities so I'm sensitive
to how those play out the National
Museum of african-american history and
culture it's probably the most
significant project have engaged in in
my career so far and and probably will
be one of the defining projects I'm sure
this is a museum where that container
and the content are one the museum's
central silhouette is derived from a
Yoruba capital head a wooden column
which holds a porch in a shrine house
this triple headed ziggurat was actually
a beautiful way of encapsulating this
universe of ideas I have a deep interest
in African Africa's Diaspora when I look
at abstractions from the continent I'm
trying to understand how abstraction was
incredibly successful in unifying
complex tribes and groups to create
ideas about larger collective
organizations
culture is intrinsically connected to
fabric society being a woven textile a
system that's interconnected and at the
strength of the societies through that
interconnectedness they much more
interested in thinking about
architecture through this notion of
fabric through interconnectedness and
through handing down of abstractions and
interconnections the Sugarhill projects
where the rose embossing was not
literally drawn but was a vector drawing
which disappeared and appeared depending
on way with sunlight operated on it and
the reason for it it was because the
land that we were occupying was farmland
your Rosa
buildings can imbue within them
narratives about geography all about
people without being mimetic or
figurative but can use narrative to
describe what that abstraction can be
about public architecture dissolves and
becomes less about form and becomes more
about scale asanas and interaction and
private architecture increasingly
becomes about havens and moments so
maybe from that you can imagine what my
ideal campus might be I think that the
campus is a very interesting question I
think it asked the campus - absolutely
weld itself with the public life of the
community
the MIT campus is interesting that
original building is really powerful for
students the architecture of that
building in its history and it's
layering of other people who've been
inspired within that environment the
architecture can dissolve itself by
dismantling certain formal commercial
and civic ideas which are to do with
sealed palaces of information to
becoming more like markets the notion of
a place of exchange becomes mayor very
interesting model for a place of
Education and learning it's not so much
about the quantity of the books anymore
because actually that can be gotten
through the internet but the quality of
the space is a gathering edifying space
is actually now very critical because as
creatures of habit and pattern we
actually like the idea of places of
stimulation I think in our century in
the 21st century our theater is about
having the tools which give you the data
but constantly reapplying the tools and
very precise ways which creates new
conditions which amplifying help society
you
you